Let the rumor slinging commence.
A few weeks ago, the guys over at We Got This
Covered reported that, according to undisclosed
sources, Kingsman and Rocketman star Taron
Egerton is high on Marvel's wish list to take
over the role of Wolverine - and now the star
himself has weighed in on the rumor.
Egerton is currently riding high on the critical
and box office success of the Elton John biopic
Rocketman, in which the actor channeled the
legendary musician to jaw-dropping effect
- even singing all of the movie's songs himself.
And while it seems that Egerton wouldn't necessarily
cast himself as Wolverine if the choice were
his, he did suggest that he'd be game to take
on the role - or, failing that, any other
role that Marvel Studios would consider him
for.
"Are we gonna stand, or are we gonna fight?"
When asked whether there was any substance
to the Wolverine rumor, Egerton said:
"That one I think is just a rumor.
As far as I'm aware, it's unfounded.
I don't know if I'm quite grisly enough.
I mean, if the people at Marvel think I am,
then great, let's go.
But I think there are probably better candidates.
But I would love to be involved with that
world somewhere."
"Oh yeah, Charles, we got ourselves an X-Men
fan."
Despite his reluctance, it's probably fair
to say that Egerton - who has proven his capability
as an action star in the Kingsman series - would
be an excellent choice for the part.
And that's a sentiment shared by the one guy
who ought to know best.
In 2016, Hugh Jackman - who famously played
Wolverine for a staggering 17 years - was
asked whether he'd be game to appear in a
Deadpool film, while doing the press rounds
for Eddie the Eagle with Egerton - who also
starred in that movie.
Jackman explained:
"I've never thought about it till now, but
doing something with [Deadpool actor] Ryan
[Reynolds] - he's awesome - that's always
attractive to me."
Gesturing to Egerton, Jackman then said:
"But I think [Marvel has] probably got several
other people lined up to play [Wolverine]…
probably you."
It's almost as if Jackman knew something everyone
else didn't, and there's a good chance that
his comment is what set the rumor mill spinning
in the first place.
At the time, of course, Disney's acquisition
of the film and television assets of Fox Studios
hadn't yet begun to take shape, but once it
became clear that the X-Men were destined
to be rebooted into the MCU, Marvel Studios
head honcho Kevin Feige swiftly expressed
his intention to recast the merry band of
mutants with much younger actors, including
Wolverine.
It makes sense to do just that, of course,
since Marvel famously likes to sign its talent
to long-term contracts, sometimes involving
as many as six pictures.
And while it goes without saying that a number
of X-fans would love to see Jackman reprise
his role in the MCU, it's safe to say that
the 50-year old Jackman probably has no desire
to go on playing Wolverine - and many of the
fan-favorite choices for the role, such as
54-year old Keanu Reeves and 41-year old Tom
Hardy - would also face the same problem.
At 29, however, Egerton could hold down the
role for the same length of time that Jackman
did.
He's also a remarkably versatile actor, equally
adept at playing a budding superspy as an
iconic rock star, and - as fans of the famously
stocky superhero will surely appreciate - he's
only five feet nine inches tall, too.
At any rate, you've got to hope that Egerton
is just being coy about his chances of taking
the role.
After all, Marvel Studios is practically peerless
when it comes to casting their heroes and
villains, and Egerton as Wolverine could just
be their masterstroke.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.